bueno esta mañana la policía del estado
de Brasilia ha intentado desmantelar un
campamento de bolsonaristas que están
desde hace semanas frente al cuartel
general del ejército de la capital hubo
resistencia incluso agresiones a los
vehículos de los agentes y lo que
destaca alguna medio de la prensa
brasileña Es que la policía del ejército
no intervino la versión oficial del
ejército es que se decidió posponer la
operación para dar más seguridad a los
agentes involucrados y mientras tanto a
las 10 de la mañana se desagrada otra
macrooperación contra personas que han
supuestamente participado en actos
definidos antidemocráticos hay al menos
cuatro arrestados y siete Fugitivos las
acusaciones son muy graves porque se
habla incluso de golpe de estado Valeria
también se conoció que el presidente
electo completó su gabinete Cuáles son
los pensamientos más destacados
lo primero que tenemos que destacar es
que hay once mujeres y 16 hombres y eso
es un punto muy importante en un país
que está la cola de las estadísticas por
presencia de mujeres en las
instituciones públicas y en el
parlamento sin duda el nombre más
importante es Marina Silva para medio
ambiente y allá fue ministra hace 15
años en el primer gobierno de Lula salió
del gobierno por desentenderse con Dilma
rosé que entonces era ministra de la
casa civil su nombramiento significa que
es real el compromiso de Lula contra la
deforestación de la amazonía el otro
grande nombre es de soniara para el
recién creado ministros de pueblos
indígenas ella es un activista muy
conocida sobre todo a nivel
internacional por las numerosas
denuncias que ha hecho en la ONU y en
otros órganos internacionales sobre las
violaciones de derechos contra los
pueblos indígenas